it was a long and at times brutal battle
but now the russians have control of the
city of lissachensk and with it the
strategically and politically important
luhansk region meeting with his defence
minister in moscow vladimir putin
thanked his soldiers and told them to
push on
i ask you to give a state award to all
service personnel who have excelled
during this military action based on
your daily reports i know there are a
lot of brave professional and gutsy in a
good way
soldiers in the russian army
they all should be decorated with all
the relevant state awards
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky
said his troops were pulled out of the
city to save their lives but he promised
to return with greater firepower to
reclaim it
if the commanders of our army recall
people from certain points of the front
where the enemy have the greatest fire
advantage in particular this also
applies to lisa cheng's it means only
one thing that we will return thanks to
our tactics thanks to the increase in
the supply of our modern weapons
the russians are now turning their
attention to targets in the donetsk
region and with luhansk those are the
two areas that russia recognized as
breakaway independent states the day
before it launched its war in ukraine
for the russians this is a major
tactical success even if their military
victory took longer than they expected
the area's governor admits the loss of
lysice is painful but he says while the
battle has been lost
the war has not
alan fisher al jazeera kiev
staying with ukraine and a school in
eastern ukraine has been flattened by
russian missiles in its second largest
city harkiv has been under heavy
bombardment since russia's invasion
began in february the ukrainian prime
minister says the conflict has caused at
least 100 billion dollars worth of
damage
i feel hatred only hatred and i can't
understand why this is happening all the
world is against president putin but
they can't stop him why and how long
will this war continue i'm speechless
when will it all stop